رغم ترحيبه بالخطط الصينيه الكريميلين
يقول ان الوضع الراهن لا يتيح فرصه
التسويه في اوكرانيا
مجلس النواب الليبي يرحب بمبادره امميه
لاجراء الانتخابات تجمع الاطراف المدنيه
والعسكريه
يعتبر توسيع المستوطنات عقبه في طريق
السلام ويطالب بتخفيف حده تصعيد بين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
اعلنا الكريم ان روسيا تاخذ خطه السلام
الصينيه على محمل التقدير وان هناك بنودا
مهمه في الخطه تتوافق مع توجهات موسكو وقد
شدد الكريم على ان العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه داخل اوكرانيا نتج عنها قضايا
ساخنه تاخذها موسكو بعين الاعتبار وفي هذا
الصدد اعلن المتحدث باسم الكرملين
لا يتيح فرصه لمناقشه تسويه في اوكرانيا
وان العمليه العسكريه الروسيه ستستمر في
اوكرانيا حتى تحقيق كافه اهدافها الكريم
لان اشار الى ان استخبارات الغرب تعمل ضد
موسكو على مدار الساعه مضيفا ان امريكا
وفرنسا وبريطانيا يقفون ايضا ضد روسيا من
خلال تزويد اوكرانيا بالمعده العسكريه
طالب دول الغرب بقياده الولايات المتحده
بتغيير منهجها تجاه المخاوف الامنيه
لروسيا حتى تستانف موسكو مشاركتها في
معاهده وقال بيسقاف انه على الغرب ان يفهم
نظريه عدم قابليه تجزئه امن روسيا وانه لا
يمكن تامين امن دوله على حساب امن دوله
اخرى
وصف الرئيس بلادي الوضع
وحولها بالصعب واضاف زيلينسكي ان القوات
الروسيه تدمر بشكل متواصل كل ما يمكن
استخدامه من قبل الجنود الاوكرانيين
لحمايه انفسهم
في قطاع مخموط يزداد الوضع صعوبه العدو
يدمر باستمرار كل ما يمكن ان نستخدمه
لحمايه مواقعنا للتحصين والدفاع جنودنا
الذين يدافعون عن المنطقه المحيطه بمخموت
هم ابطال حقيقيون
اضاف الرئيس قائلا ان بلاده بحاجه الى
طائره حربيه حديثه وانها لا تستطيع الدفاع
عن اجواءها الا اذا تم رفعه حظر الطيران
بشكل كامل
بسبب الضربات الروسيه المتواصله نحتاج الى
طائرات حربيه حديثه لحمايه كامل اراضي
دولتنا من الارهاب الروسي يكتمل الدفاع
الجوي عندما يكون لدينا طائرات حديثه
طيارون والوحدات المضاده للطائرات وغيرهم
خبراء سلاح الجو يقومون بعمل رائع سنكون
قادرين على حمايه اجوائنا عندما يتم رفع
حظر الطيران بالكامل
نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني هنا مليار ان
الروسي يزيدون من حده الهجمات في دوناتسك
واضافت مليار ان الوضع على الجبهه صعب
للغايه مشيره الى انه اصعب الجبهات هي
بخموت واكدت نائبه وزير دفاع اوكرانيا ان
روسيا تستخدم تكتيكات لارهاق القوات
الاوكرانيه ثم تدميرها بشكل كامل واضافت
ان روسيا تتفوق عدديا في هذه المرحله
وصف رئيس وزراء المجره فيكتور اوربان
الخطه الصينيه للسلام في اوكرانيا بالمهمه
وبشان قضيه انضمام اوكرانيا الى النيتو
قال انه سيتم طرح هذا الموضوع عاجلا ام
اجلا اضاف اوربان انه يجب التفكير كثيرا
في التوسع الاضافي للنيتو في الشرق حتى لا
تنجذب الى حرب
رحب البيت الابيض على لساني المتحدث باسم
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كاربي رحب
بزياره وزير خارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان لاوكرانيا ونتائجها وفي رد على
سؤال العربيه قال السعوديه تقوم بخطوات
كبيره لدعم استقرار المنطقه وندعم السعودي
للشعب الاوكراني خطوه مهمه
السعوديه تعتبر شركه استراتيجيا للولايات
المتحده منذ ثمانيه عقود ونحن نرحب بزياره
وزير خارجيه السعوديه لاوكرانيا ونتائجها
خصوصا ان اعلان مساعدات بقيمه 400 مليون
دولار ستساعد اوكرانيا كثيرا كما ان الدعم
السعودي للشعب الاوكراني يشكل خطوه مهمه
اضافه الى ذلك فان السعوديه تقوم بخطوات
كبيره لدعم استقرار المنطقه
لها على الحدود البولنديه الاوكرانيه رصدت
كاميرا
على اوكرانيين الذين لم يتوقف عبورهم
المنطقه الحدوديه نحو بولندا وان كانت
اعدادهم قد تراجعت نسبيا
لا تتوقفوا قوافل نقل المساعدات العسكريه
الى اوكرانيا ولا ينقطع التدفق مساعدات
انسانيه عبر شاحنات تنتظر طويلا عند
الحدود وصلنا الى اقصى جنوب شرق بولندا
هنا تقع حدود اوكرانيا مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومع حلف النيتو وهو ما يفسر خشيه
البولنديين الدائمه من ان يصبحوا يوما خط
التماس الاول في المواجهه بين موسكو
والغرب الغرب دخل في تصعيد كلامي حاد ضد
روسيا حتى ان فرنسا اول الداعين الى
الحوار سابقا باتت تتحدث عن مواصله دعم
اوكرانيا حتى النصر اليوم امر
الوقت الحاضر ومسانده بكل الوسائل الممكنه
لاوكرانيا حتى تدافع عن
نفسي نفسها نحن
اليوم مع اوكرانيا بكل وسايلنا هذا النصره
استرجاع اوكرانيا اراضيها المحتله
استرجاع سيادتها وسلامتها قبل عام دخل عبر
هذه الحدود الى بولندا حوالي تسعه ملايين
لاجئ اوكرانيا توزع معظمهم لاحقا على دول
اوروبيه مجاوره اليوم تراجعت اعداد
الهاربين من الحرب لكنها لم تتوقف بعد عام
على بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا ما زالت محطه
قطارات هنا عند الجانب البولندي من الحدود
بين البلدين نقطه استراحه عابره للاجئين
الاوكرانيين قبل انطلاقهم نحو وجهه جديده
المئات منهم ينتظرون هنا منذ ساعات بعد ان
قدموا من مدينه
جنوب شرق اوكرانيا وهم ينتظرون هنا القطار
الذي
سيستقلونه للوصول اولا الى العاصمه
البولنديه ومن هناك يتجه ون نحو مدينه
هانوفر الالمانيه صور اللاجئين هنا تعكس
استمرار محنه الاوكرانيين وحاجاتهم الماسه
الى الاغاثه الدوليه
[موسيقى]
نقدم للاجئين دعما بالمعلومات ونساعدهم
للحصول على كل ما يحتاجون اليه من ايجاد
ماوى ووسيله نقل ونجيب على كل اسئلتهم الى
هذه المحطه الواقعه عند الحدود البولنديه
يصل يوميا من اوكرانيا حوالى الفيلاجئ
بدلا من عشرات الالاف يوميا قبل عام حسين
قنيبر العربيه من منطقه الحدود البولنديه
الاوكرانيه
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
اضرار تركيا الماديه المباشره جراء
الزلزال المدمر تتجاوز 34 مليار دولار
اهلا بكم من جديد رحب مجلس النواب الليبي
بالمبادره الامميه التي تهدف الى اجراء
انتخابات حره ونزيهه وثمن المجلس دور
البعثه الامميه في هذا الصدد اكد المجلس
على ان الليبيين هم الضامن الوحيد لانجاح
اي مبادره في هذا الشان وطلب مجلس النواب
في بيان المجتمع الدولي بدعم المؤسسات
الليبيه في الاطلاع بمهامها لاسيما تلك
المتعلقه باقرار التشريعات الانتخابيه
وقوانين تنظيم الانفاق العام كما طالب
بتفعيل الاليات الدوليه ضد من يعملون على
مصادره عمل المؤسسات الشريكه في المسار
السياسي ومعرقلين في هذه التشريعي تشريعات
كما اعرب المجلس عن رفضه التام لاي تدخل
بجهود المؤسسه الامنيه
نتابع في الشان الليبي ايضا حيث قالت
الامم المتحده ان المبعوثه الليبي سيطلق
مبادره تهدف الى تمكين الانتخابات
التشريعيه والرئاسيه هذا العام وسيشكل
لجنه توجيهيه رفيعه المستوى واقل المبعوث
عبد الله بطيلي ان الاليه ستجمع بين
ممثلين مؤسسات السياسيه وشخصيات السياسيه
الرئيسيه وزعماء القبائل ومنظمات المجتمع
المدني والمسؤولين الامنيين والجماعات
الاخرى ذات الصله
قدر البنك الدولي اضرار زلزال السادس من
فبراير في تركيا بنحو
34.2 مليار دولار مؤكدا ان كل فتى اعاده
الاعمار ستكون اعلى بمرتين من ذلك الرقم
وان العمليه ستخفض نمو الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي بمقدار نصف نقطه مئويه خلال
العام الحالي
بانتظارك شعار يتم تداوله على نطاق واسع
واستجاب له سكان بلده كارخان الحدوديه مع
سوريا يحاولون العوده تدريجيا الى حياتهم
الطبيعيه رغم اثار الزلزال المحيطه بهم من
كل جانب
يعني
من اجل مواصله الحياه والبقاء في البلاد
والحفاظ عليها رغم الزلازل ومخلفاتها يجب
علينا استئناف عملنا لتستمر الحياه خلال
الزلزال قتل ما يقارب سته الاف شخص من
ابناء هذه البلده التي كانت تعداد سكانها
يفوق الاربع مئه الف نسمه نصفهم من
السوريين
والله على الله شفت عينك يعني
انشغل
الله يعزك شغلات مزبطين امورنا وقبل زلزال
كان وضعكم احسن والله
فوق الرحله
والله بيوتنا نفوت بيها
يعني نقول نجذب نفوت على البيت مثل
الحرامي ناخذ قرض ونطلع
هذه واحده من عشرات المساحات الجارفه
لتتحول الى مدن مؤقته الفحاويه ببلده
كارخان يتم تجهيزها لتكون مساكن صالحه
لاواء الاف المتضررين من ضحايا الزلزال
عبد القادر خربوش العربيه بلده كارخان على
الحدود التركيه السوريه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
في ردد على سؤال للعربيه ان موقف واشنطن
من المستوطنات الاسرائيليه الثابت ويعتبر
توسيع او يعتبروا توسيع المستوطنات عقبه
في طريق السلام كاربي اضافانا العنف الذي
حدث في نابلس من حرق لمنازل الفلسطينيين
من قبل المستوطنين هو مجرد مثال اخر على
اهميه جمع الجانبين الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي
معا للعمل على طرق للتخفيف من حده تصيد
موقفنا من المستوطنات ثابت ولم يتغير حيث
نعتبر توسيع المستوطنات عقبه في طريق
السلام والعنف الذي رايناه مؤخرا في نابلس
هو مجرد مثال اخر على اهميه ان نجمع
الجانبين الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي معا للعمل
على تخفيف حده التصعيد وبرغم ما حدث لا
يزال هناك مؤشرات جيده على الاقل حول
استعداد الطرفين لخفض التصيد وهو ما
رايناه من بيانات الجانب الاسرائيلي التي
تدين ما فعله المستوطنون
احتج طلاب جامعه طهران وخرجوا في مظاهرات
ضد قرار التعليم عن بعد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اعلانات محكمه مونتريال انها حكمت بالسجن
لمده تسع سنوات على الايرانيين نادر
جيرمان بتهمه غسيل الاموال والتحويل غير
القانوني من والى ايران والصين ولبنان وقد
فرضت غرامه قدرها 920 الف دولار ومصادره
ممتلكاته التي قدرت بنحو خمسه ملايين
دولار
غادر عدد من المشاركين في اجتماع الامم
المتحده لحقوق الانسان في جناب الجلسه
خلال حديث وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين
امير عبد الله
[موسيقى]
تقرير ان حكومي امريكي نشرته صحيفه
حول انهيار الجيش الافغاني وتركي معدات
بقيمه مليارات الدولارات تحت سيطره حركه
طالبان بعد انسحاب القوات الامريكيه في
اغسطس 2021
ثمانيه عشر شهرا مرت على الانسحاب
الامريكي من افغانستان
صعدت بعده مباشره حركه طالبان الى السلطه
مغيره المشهد السياسي بشكل جذري في البلد
الذي عان لسنوات
الانسحاب الامريكي فاجا الحكومه السابقه
في افغانستان وفق تقرير حكومي نشرته صحيفه
وولس
التقرير الذي جرى بطلب من الكونجرس
الامريكي والذي سيناقشه قريبا اتهم
البنتاجون بعدم التعاون مع التحقيق حول
انهيار الجيش الافغاني وانه لم يقدم الدعم
الامني للحكومه الافغانيه السابقه كما وعد
ضمن بنود الانسحاب مما سمح بانهيار الجيش
والحكومه وصعود طالبان الى السلطه خلال
ايام معدوده
كما اشار الى تقديم البنتاجون لاجابات غير
كامله على الاسئله لترد وزاره الدفاع
بدورها انها تعاونت مع التحقيق قائله انها
قدمت ردودا مكتوبه على اسئله المفتش العام
جورنال نقلا عن التقرير الامريكي القت
باللوم على اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن التي لم تلتزم باتفاق انسحاب القوات
الامريكيه بين طالبان واداره ترامب ما ادى
لانتقادات بين الحزبين الرئيسيين طالت
الرئيس بايدن عدا عن الاتهامات بسوء تخطيط
الانسحاب وعدم الاهتمام بحمايه المتعاقدين
الافغان كما كشفت المعلومات عن ترك
الولايات المتحده معدات عسكريه وراءها في
افغانستان بقيمه تزيد عن سبعه مليارات
دولار بين الطائرات وصواريخ واسلحه ومعدات
اتصال
سبعه مليارات دولار من المعدات الصالحه
للعمل من اصل 18 مليارا انفقتها امريكا
على تسليح الجيش الافغاني الذي انهار في
ساعات معدوده
التقرير ختم باهميه عدم تكرار التجربه
الافغانيه في اوكرانيا منبها الى ضروره
مراقبه المساعدات العسكريه التي تقدمها
الولايات المتحده لكييف قائلا ان التورط
الامريكي في هذه الصراعات اظهر عدم القدره
على التعلم من الاخطاء
رحب رئيس الفرنسي مانيويل ماكو عبر صفحته
الرسميه على موقع تويتر بالانفاق بين او
بالاتفاق عفوا بين المملكه المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي بشان تنفيذ اطار عملي
ما بعد خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الاوروبي
في ايرلندا الشماليه
وصف القرار بالمهم وقال انه يحمي السوق
داخليه الاوروبيه
رئيس الحكومه البريطانيه
اذ توصل الى اتفاق مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
لحل مشاكل البروتوكول ايرلندا الشماليه
الذي يخضع هذا الاقليم التابعه للتاجر
البريطاني بعد لقوانين السوق الاوروبيه
الموحده للحفاظ على حدود مفتوحه بين
ايرلندا الشماليه وجارتها الجنوبيه العضو
في الاتحاد الاوروبي كما يفرض اجراءات
تفتيش جمركيه للبضائع من انحاء بريطانيا
الى هذه المقاطعه الشماليه سوناك اشاد
بهذا الاختراق الحاسم
عن يسعدني ان ابلغكم اننا حققنا تقدما
حاسما معا قمنا بتغيير البروتوكول الاصلي
ونعلن اليوم عن اطار عمل الدستور الجديد
توفر اتفاقيه اليوم تدفقا سلسا للتجاره
داخل المملكه المتحده باكملها وتحمي مكانه
ايرلندا الشماليه في اتحادنا وتحمي
السياده لشعب ايرلندا الشماليه
اطار عمل وينزر جاء نتيجه التوتر الذي
اثاره بروتوكول ايرلندا الشماليه بتعطيل
عمل السلطه التنفيذيه المحليه لاكثر من
سنه ناهيك عن بيروقراطيه نقل البضائع الى
المقاطعه الشماليه وستتيح هذه التسويه
الجديده توافر جميع المواد الغذائيه
والادويه البريطانيه في اسواق ارندا
الشماليه عبر مسارين واحد اخضر للبضائع
المتوجهه لايرلندا الشماليه واخر احمر
للبضائع الذي قد تتوجه للاتحاد الاوروبي
كما تعطي المجلس المحلي رايا في القوانين
الاوروبيه التي تحكمهم
لقد توصلنا الى اتفاق في اطار عمل يفرض
تسويه جديده فيما يخص ايرلندا وايرلندا
الشماليه اطار العمل سيكون بدايه لفصل
جديد بيننا ويؤمن حلولا طويله الامد والتي
ستناسب الجميع في ايرلندا الشماليه
ان الاتفاق الجديد مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
بشان بروتوكول ايرلندا الشماليه يصحح عيوب
والتحدي الذي يواجه ريشيسوناك الان هو
اقناع الاطراف السياسيه هنا في بريطانيا
لقبول هذه التسويه الجديده
على راس هؤلاء الحزب الوحدوي الديمقراطي
في بلفاست الذي جمد صيغه تقاسم السلطه وفق
معاهده السلام بسبب البروتوكول الذي اثر
على التجاره بين بريطانيا وايروندا
الشماليه لابقاء هذه المقاطعه في السوق
الموحده كما سيكون على سوناك كسب اعضاء
حزبه وخاصه جناحه المتشدد في مجموعه
الابحاث الاوروبيه فيما ابدت المعارضه
تاييدها للاتفاق لازالته عقبات وتصحيح
اخطاء البروتوكول السابق مصطفى العربيه
لندن
قالت جل بايدن سيده الولايات المتحده ان
زوجها الرئيس جو بايدن يعتزم ترشح لولايه
ثانيه وانها تؤيد ذلك تماما حتى مع عدم
اصدار اعلان رسمي بنوايه بعد وعقلت او قال
بايدن نفسه مرارا انه يعتزم الترشح لاعاده
انتخابه ورفض الاسئله المتعلقه بسنه لكنه
لم يصدر اعلانا رسميا بعد
حضرت الحكومه الكنديه تطبيق تيك توك على
كل هواتفها واجهزتها مشيره الى مخاوف على
صعيد حمايه البيانات وجاء في بيان الحكومه
انه اعتبارا من اليوم الثلاثاء سيتم حذف
تطبيق تيك توك عن الاجهزه المحموله التي
تمنحها الحكومه كما سيتم منح مستخدمي هذه
الاجهزه من تنزيل التطبيق او منعهم من
تنزيل التطبيق في المستقبل
كما ان البيت الابيض الهيئه الحكوميه
ثلاثين يوما لتاكد من عدم وجود تطبيق تيك
توك على اي من الاجهزه والانظمه التابعه
للحكومه الاتحاديه واقلت مديره مكتب
الاداره والميزانيه سلندا يوم للجهه
الحكوميه في مذكره توجيهيه انه سيكون
مطلوبا منها تعديل عقود تكنولوجيا
المعلومات لتاكد من ان المتعاقدين يحمون
بيانات الولايات المتحده من خلال وقف
استخدام تيك توك على الاجهزه والانظمه
المستخدمه في اطار عملهم
كشف التقارير اعلاميه فرنسيه ان السلطات
الفرنسيه تحقق مع الدولي المغربي اشرف
حكيمي لاعب باريس سان جيرمان بعد ان زعمت
شاب انها تعرضت للاغتصاب من قبل اللاعب
نهايه الاسبوع الماضي ووفقا لتقرير او
تقارير الاعلاميه فنشابه لا ترغب في تقديم
شكوى بل الكشف عن اغتصابها من قبل حكيمه
وتولى مكتب المدعي العام القضيه ويعمل
المحققون على الملف الذي تم تجميعه على
اساس اقوال المدعيه
ختم هذه النشره الى العناوين
رغم ترحيبه بالخطط الصينيه الكرملين يقول
ان الوضع الراهن لا يتيح فرصه تسويه في
اوكرانيا
مجلس النواب الليبي يرحب بمبادره امميه
لاجراء الانتخابات تجمع الاطراف المدنيه
والعسكريه
يعتبر توسيع المستوطنات عاقبه في طريق
السلام ويطالب بتخفيف حده تصعيد بين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
دائما العربيه
[موسيقى]